bueno definitivamente este es un
fenómeno multidimensional no se ha
registrado como bien señalas t a partir
de un proceso de ilusión regresiva
natural y un socavón de tierra pero esto
responde a su vez a una historia de una
pésima gestión pública alrededor del
control ambiental y también es una
respuesta estructural de cierta forma en
el sentido de un modelo económico
insostenible e irresponsable a partir de
eso tenemos dos dimensiones
fundamentales de afectación por un lado
la dimensión ambiental teniendo en
cuenta que es un lugar de sensibilidad
ecológica con un alto nivel de
biodiversidad y por otro lado una
dimensión social que tiene que ver con
la salud con la afectación en cuanto a
la contaminación del agua y a la
soberanía alimentaria de las poblaciones
y de las comunidades aledañas
principalmente de pueblos originarios